I've barely become interested in the
idea that the sense of engagement of
meaningful engagement is the deepest of
cognitive instincts I actually think you
can make a very strong neurobiological
case for that and that that if you're
engaged in something what it means is
that you're safe and secure on the one
hand sufficiently safe and secure you're
in your domain of competence which is a
good place to be you know it's like
explored territory
so you're within the walls where you're
safe but you're also peering over the
fence at the same time right so if
you're engaged what it means is that
you're in your domain of competence but
you're operating within that domain of
competence so that you expanding your
competence at the same time and so you
feel that as meaningfully engaged
meaningfully engaging and it is and so
what I do also think that that sense of
meaningful engagement is the right
antidote to the suffering that's that's
that's part and parcel of our limited
existence it's like you need an antidote
to the fact that life is suffering and
the experience of meaningful engagement
I think is that antidote and I also
think that the experience of meaningful
engagement is a marker that you're where
you should be doing what you should be
at the right time yeah I think it's the
deepest of cognitive incidence and so
that's really cool man if that was true
I think it's actually true if I if I'm
in the zone properly it's ridiculously
fascinating yeah because people are
ridiculously interesting and so and and
everyone has their own characteristic
experience that's actually unique and so
if you have a real conversation with
someone and they tell you what's unique
about their experience the probability
that you can learn something from that
is but it's certain that you can I've
been using the term dominance hierarchy
a lot which it's something that's used
by biologists very regularly right
because most social animals even animals
that aren't social any animals that have
to compete for occupation of a specific
territorial space tend to organize
themselves into fairly predictable
hierarchies and it's it's it's a
biological Universal that's a good way
of thinking about it which is something
really important to know right because
if you don't know that then you might
think that hierarchical organizations
are some secondary consequence of a
socio-political structure and economic
structure something like that and it's
just that's just not true it isn't even
a little bit true it's unbelievably not
true
if you look at
career choices between men and women
what you find is that they're driven in
large part by temperamental differences
so that would be in the big five
extraversion neuroticism agreeableness
conscientiousness and openness and also
by interest because the biggest
difference between men and women that's
been measured psychometrically forget
about the physical differences but
psychological differences is difference
in interest and it's actually pretty big
and so men on average are more
interested in things and women on
average are more interested in people
and it's a one standard deviation
difference which is a big difference by
the standards of these sorts of
differences it's extraordinarily
reliable it is as far as I'm concerned
apart from the hard biological end of
this of psychology where there's some
unbelievably solid work done it's the
most solid social science that exists as
far as I can tell the psychometric data
and the reason I think that is when I
was starting my career um I was looking
for the most solid data because one of
the things I wanted to do was learn how
to predict how people's lives
transformed and changed and across time
and and what sort of level of
achievement they managed so I was
looking for the most reliable and valid
measures and it's clearly the
psychometric measures are the most
reliable and valid period no one
disputes that
well there are a variety of features
that predict economic success in the
Western world then the most outstanding
of those are IQ so that's straight
intelligence and intelligence is
something like processing speed and
working memory capacity so it's the
ability to manipulate variables a number
of variables simultaneously at
relatively high speeds that's and
they're abstract variables and the Armed
Forces concluded that if you had an IQ
of 83 or less there wasn't anything you
could possibly be trained to do in the
military at any level of the
organization that wasn't positively
counterproductive
okay you think well so what 83 okay yeah
one in ten
one in ten that's one in ten people and
that what that really means that as far
as I can tell is if you imagine that the
military is approximately as complex as
the broader society which i think is a
reasonable proposition then there's no
place in our cognitively complex society
for one in ten people so what are we
going to do about that
the answer is no one knows the best way
to sum up a conscientious person is that
they're very good at keeping contracts
with themselves and others so what a
conscientious person will do is first of
all say that they'll do some things so
that's the first thing but then they'll
actually do it you'd hope if a system is
functioning that faster harder working
people would be better at whatever it
does and it turns out that in our
culture in the Western culture the
correlation between conscientiousness
plus IQ you have to wait the two and
long term life success is as high as 0.7
which is walloping walloping correlation
in their Radek ability of inequality
so part of the problem with this process
that we just described where success
breeds success and failure breeds
failure is that the people who are
succeeding get a disproportionate share
of the resource pie let's say so the
same rule applies to number of records
sold by recording artists the same rule
applies to number of books sold by
novelist the same rule applies to number
of goals scored by NHL hockey players
the same rule applies to the population
of cities and the mass of stars and the
size of trees in the in the jungle it's
like the inequality problem is way more
troublesome again than mere capitalism
it's a terrible problem well let's say
you find a Neolithic burial site and
there's 200 people in it so these people
would be buried with their possessions
and obviously some of them decay but
some of them don't and like some of them
are buried with gold well hardly any of
them and the tiny proportion of people
who are buried with gold are buried with
a lot of gold well even in
hunter-gatherer societies where there's
no surplus there's still inequality
because there's inequality of friendship
there's inequality of health and there's
inequality of sexual access and those
things are they are not trivial but when
you're thinking about it purely
economically you start to get an
inequality as soon as you get a surplus
you think oh that's interesting so
there's a natural rule which is surplus
generates inequality alright so how do
you solve that and shy Dells book says
well that's easy
you just get rid of the surplus
right and that's not good the thing is
is that a meritocracy will drive
inequality and then you have a problem
because people stack up at zero and they
can't get out of zero because that's
what happens as inequality increases
people think about when you're playing
Monopoly
you know the game I mean that's a
perfect example of how inequality
emerges everybody is equal to begin with
everybody basically plays a random game
because monopoly is basically a random
game I mean there's some skill in it but
not much so so it's a random game so
what happens when everyone starts equal
and you play a random game one person
ends up with everything everyone else
stacks up at zero now shy Dells book
basically shows the only way out of that
is various forms of war including
revolution and epidemics that's it
that's the only thing he's been able to
track that and and what happens is well
you level everyone and then the
inequality decreases it's like well okay
like that doesn't seem like a really
great solution now that doesn't mean I
think that people of disproportionate
intelligence shouldn't be rewarded
disproportionately it's possible that
they should because it might be in the
best interest of everyone else to dump
as much money as possible to the top 2%
of the cognitive strata because they're
going to be most generative with it it's
clear that as inequality increases
societies destabilized that's clear so
it's something that has to be dealt with
and but we don't know how to deal with
it we don't know how to efficiently move
resources to the bottom end of the
competence hierarchy so that things
don't destabilize I would say that the
long term solution assuming that there
is one to the problem of inequality is
that people who are disproportionately
fortunate let's say or successful or
both
upon take the moral duty of doing the
best possible good that they can with
the money that they generate correct but
the other thing I think that's sort of
interesting about that is I actually
don't think there's anything more
interesting to do with your money that
work it's like can you think of anything
more interesting to do with your money
than to find a really difficult problem
that causes a bunch of people suffering
and then try to fix it it's like amazing
if you have a clue that's got to be a
little better than a third yacht
confidence a good measure of competence
would be the ability to work within the
hierarchy while you're also expanding
maintaining it and expanding it and so
you that means that you would want to
set up an economic system where smart
hard-working people were doing things
that made other people who weren't them
rich too and I think we're actually
pretty good at that and then the person
who's a little more generous than
reciprocal you know fifty-fifty would be
reciprocal maybe you should err on the
side of generosity why easily easy
people will line up to play with you so
then the question is do you want to win
the game or do you want to win the set
of games right and I think I think
there's rules that govern the set of all
possible games and it's the rules that
govern the set of all possible games
that constitute something like an
emergent ethic so anyway so that's a
very useful thing to know it's a very
useful thing to know banks have
discovered the play circuitry in mammals
and that's also a big deal right that's
like discovering a continent to discover
a dedicated circuitry to a set of
complex biological functions that's a
big deal man you a pair of these rats
together and what you find is that so
the little rat has to ask the big rat to
play in the big rattle like you know
break is cool and then wrestle and then
if you pair them repeatedly unless the
big rat lets the little rat win 30% of
the time the little rat will no longer
ask him to play like that I read that it
was like little electrical storm went
off in my bag is what happened to me -
oh it's so good so I'm so absolutely
unbelievable is that well there you have
it some urgent ethic of reciprocity that
ethic emerged at the biological level
and then human beings watched it develop
and told stories about it that's where
the stories came from and then out of
the stories we coded an explicit ethic
and that's where the philosophy of
ethics came from but it
urged from the bottom up the UN said is
one of its millennial goals in the year
2000 to have the rates of poverty in the
world by 50% within 15 years right and
we hit that in 2012 three years ahead of
schedule it was the fastest decrease in
human poverty that has ever occurred in
the history of the planet by a massive
margin and it hasn't quit now obesity is
a bigger problem now than starvation
it's like we should have party in the
street for that right there's more fat
people than there are starving people
you know it's a perverse sort of victory
but but it's a big one and about three
hundred thousand people a day right now
are being plugged into the electrical
grid and the fastest-growing economies
are in sub-sahara Africa sub-saharan
Africa it's like there's some real
reason to be thinking things are going
great it's it's like asking whether you
can reduce consciousness - material - to
its material substrate and after that is
yes but by the time we reduce
consciousness to its material substrate
our understanding of what that material
substrate is will have transformed so
dramatically that it won't look very
much like the material substrate that we
presume now and so if we're in a
simulation then it's within the confines
of a mechanism that we can't easily
assimilate to our own computational
devices
you